so I'm self-employed independent data
science consultant I'm not gonna spend
too much time talking about myself so
you can check out my website if you're
interested in what I do I live in
Richmond Virginia and I've been doing
data mining for about a decade and a
half now so a quick agenda of what we
are going to talk about today the first
five to ten minutes five to seven
minutes we're gonna talk about what is
dimensionality reduction when should we
use it and why should our data
scientists use dimensionality reduction
techniques right so and then the
majority of the talk is about how to do
it this is the emphasis of this talk is
on practicality of things right so I was
not trying to get into too much fear
theory but we'll talk more about the
tactical being to do this finished
poverty reduction techniques I have some
Python code as well which you guys can
probably review after the talk the video
will be on the website
we won't have too much time to go
through the whole line but I'll give you
a brief idea of what what goes on in
those snippets of code and then finally
five to ten minutes will I'll be having
lots of questions so please follow the
French questions until the end so first
question is what is the men's body our
featured reduction technique right what
is it
so it is basically a process of
selecting a subset of features to be
used in the bottom right so so it
belongs to the pre-processing of data
step in your data science project so
before you actually start using start
testing different machine learning
techniques if you have thousands of
thousands of variables in yourself then
it makes sense to try to use
conventionality and reduce the number of
variables that we have in your dataset
to a manageable reasonable number before
we actually try machine learning
techniques and see which model actually
is best for your data it can be useful
for both supervised and unsupervised
techniques
but for this talk maybe not focus on
supervised classification problem I will
actually talk briefly about the
unsupervised how it can be useful for
unsupervised as well but most of the
stuff is about supervised classification
problem so just a quick question for you
guys actually how many of you are there
scientist thank you
so the really the dimensionality
reduction technique this whole process
belongs to kind of the art aspect of
data science right data science is very
widely very very common commonly used
term nowadays and if you use the term
without realizing often that there's a
lot of art involved with big data
science right so a lot of the stuff that
I'm going to talk about here really
belongs to that that aspect of the
science there is some recipe so to speak
for sure but a lot of times when you
have different in yourself different
industry different business problem you
will have to improvise you will have
used different rules of thumb and you
have to kind of adapt this wrong is that
right so when I think I briefly already
talked about when we would use
dimensionality reduction techniques so
this is you might have seen this flow
chart of their own class supervised
learning problem a different version of
this might be but usually everything
starts with like a business problem or
some kind of problem right then you
start looking at the data you create
variables you create that tabular format
vectorized Lee does that and then you
it's kind of tempting to go directly
from a vectorized data directly to
modeling right so I've seen that happen
a lot of times right but but it is not
the best way to do it right you would
actually want to spend a lot of time
imputing transforming and preparing a
data from one and there are definitely a
lot of advantages of doing that and it's
hard
so this is where the dimensionality
reduction techniques are gonna fall
under there are many techniques that are
that that you should use before you
actually build your model but there are
some other techniques that that I'd like
to be embedded with the machine learning
algorithm itself themself so we'll talk
about those as well so the data I'm
gonna use for this talk is it's come
from one of the cattle challenges in
live data some of you might be familiar
with that there are there were nineteen
hundred and thirty three variables and
hundred and forty five thousand records
so the goal was to use those features to
predict which customers are likely to
buy response from a keen golfer right so
the challenge was really twofold you
were supposed to create new features
using the already existing like large
number of features 1933 you were
supposed to create new features and you
were supposed to employ feature
selection methods to actually identify
the best part right so the first part of
the challenge becomes from numeric
variables so I have actually done that
and that's actually I'm not going to
talk about how I created new variables
that's probably a kind of a different
talk right how to create new variables
how to create features and so what we're
going to focus on is obviously the
feature selection methods so as I said
earlier right why not just this using
sideline you know love stipulation
package you can read the data in hand as
using one line for the phone they
descend into right you would have a you
could argue that you could have a
reasonable model using just this
technique that kitchen sink approach
right you may end up you may have a area
under the curve which is more than 0.5
so you are still doing better than a
client answer right but there's better
way to do that so why would you not want
to do that because so there are several
reasons right so the two dimensionality
in your data is usually very very small
then the observed dimensionality right
so especially in the age of big data
that we all live in there are so many
features available about customer about
persons about individuals products so
when you're trying to solve a specific
business problem not all of those things
are going to be important for that
prediction right it's gonna be a smaller
set of variables that's gonna be useful
curse of dimensionality is another
factor to keep in mind right so for a
given number of observations if you
increase the number of variables then
your accuracy is gonna suffer I have
more permutations and more variables in
your data in your in your model it also
matters what value you are trying to
provide using your are you only trying
to come up with the best predictive
mathematically accurate model that you
can using a data or are you also trying
to provide some kind of explanation
right now this is usually very
applicable I do a lot of data science
modeling for marketing in the marketing
industry so it's not just about
predicting it's not about just building
the best model that you can you actually
have to come up with some type of
explanation which variables are having
relation important law of parsimony that
are the one right if you can build a
pretty strong model using 15 variables
then why in two thousand fifteen hundred
right simpler explanations are generally
bettered ceteris paribus overfitting is
an issue so if you're not being careful
with cross-validation then so many
variables it's very easy to or fit your
model an execution time is important as
well right so if you build a model with
thousands of variables and you may have
a very strong model but then you
actually production-wise it and it goes
into
deployment it would have to create those
the process having created those 1,500
variables every time you score the model
right so it's gonna it's gonna take at
all
sometime so those are the factors right
you want to keep in mind those are
actually reasons why dimensionality
reduction techniques are actually useful
it's not it's not necessarily activity
of the model right exactly
many other things right that we talked
about on the previous slide so these are
the twelve techniques that I'm talking
about probably to an hour to five
minutes on each one
in general they can be categorized into
four or five categories right initially
we'll start with some very simple
techniques that actually evaluates each
variable on itself in and off by itself
and see how much information those
variables are bringing then we'll start
looking at pairs of variables and see
the variables and then some of the
variables are redundant predictive power
is another another thing you look at I
follow how predictive they are how much
correlation they have with the target
that you are trying to model then there
are some really selection techniques the
forward step forward selection backward
elimination and stepwise and then
finally there are a million methods the
last two the first one is pretty
straightforward
right person is missing values so look
at how many would come how often each
variable is missing in your meal right
some some variables might be missing 50%
of the time my others might be 90% of
the time so many hotels for thousands of
variables you can actually afford to
drop some variables potentially the
variables I'm missing most often I
always almost always recommend creating
binary indicators as well right so they
are often come out to be very predictive
at doing these models because missing
actually does have some meaning often
right if if for telecom industry for
example when I worked a lot missing and
probably in that they don't have that
feature right if you missing
or something they just don't have an app
or they just don't have that feature so
missing does have meaning and the
missing value indicators can be often
very useful and then review or visualize
variables right so I don't recommend
dropping stuff without looking at them
usually you want to try to inspect those
variables closely and see what makes
sense so this is a distribution there
are more than 5,000 variables now
because I created so many but you can
see that there are about thousand or so
variables that have some missing values
right there are some variables here at
the top they're not missing very often
so some of the rules of thumb that I
used now that these are really kind of
timelines right so you know you wanna
make decisions based on whatever
distribution you have for your dataset
but if the variable is more than 95 or
sometimes missing then next sense to
drop them you could actually make sure
that that those variables even if they
are populated on 5% of the time you can
actually check their combination with
the target to make sure that you don't
use meaningful variables if so then you
would try to do some kind of I mean
imputation doesn't make sense in that
case because they are missing 90 percent
of the time but you could try some
interactions or something right the
variable is missing more than 50% of the
time then may not make sense to impute
them with something else right less than
50% index actually view them but anyway
so so that's the general idea right and
then any any missing values any variable
that has missing values I'm going to
create binary flags and then check their
correlation with the target to see which
one actually I want to keep it's very
easy to doing in python using pandas if
you have X's your inner matrix then you
can just do ex not describe to get the
non missing account and then you can
calculate the person is missing the
second one is simple as well amount of
variation right so how much variation
those variables
in the data if the variables don't very
much
then they may not have a lot of
information in them so it may make sense
about them if you have your neo
standardized then you can look at the
variants but if not then first one then
you can just use it up look at the
standard deviation so there are about
finite variables in this data and
sometimes you would see a curve like
this right like something like this
where it is easy to see that some
animals don't very much so you would
actually get rid of the tail right
because they converge but in this case
it's kind of a mean here trend so
there's my authorial in this car
definitely there are 39 variables that
have zero variation so you want to talk
them they're not gonna add anything to
the model so now let's start looking at
the pairwise correlations right had a
pairs of variables so you would evaluate
each and every pairs of variables in a
data you look at the correlation
coefficient coefficients among them
between them and you would drop one
variable right if there are how many
correlated then it makes sense to keep
one and drop the other so which variable
you want to keep the one that has a
higher quality within the target right
but that's how you can make those pairs
so so now we kind of start getting into
the multicollinearity aspect but just
evaluating the bivariate correlation
coefficients the pairwise so this is a
example of a correlation maybe this is
an illustrative example actually so
absolute correlation coefficients are
shown here that's the first step then
you identify variables there are pairs
of variables that I have any coordinated
so you would come up with some kind of
tolerance and you can play around with
that little bit right so I this this is
what I use normally so in this case x1
and x3 are having correlated then you
look at their correlation with the
target and the variable that has a
higher correlation with the target wins
the other one can can be dropped right
so so this is how I'm doing it in Python
it's a lot of code here but
I'll just briefly so basically the idea
is this right so when you evaluate a
correlation matrix what I do is I go
column by column in the correlation
matrix identify the pairs that are
heavily correlated then then look at the
the correlation with y and in this case
X 3 actually is something I want to drop
so I would drop that column drop that
row and then really great through the
correlation matrix so you don't have to
actually browse it rain through your
entire dataset you just actually want
from the correlation matrix so it can
work very very fast so that's what I'm
doing here in order to do the drop the
rows I'm using a mask array N P stands
for numpy so delete the row at the
bottom and delete the column if the
variable does not have a higher
correlation with the target right yes
linear relationships nonlinear so what
are you you're concerned about the
correlation with Y or just between axes
there could be yeah so there could be
nonlinear multicollinearity in the data
I actually don't know one of the things
that do is actually transform the
variables in a nonlinear fashion using
decision tree right so so you have
something like income for example right
so I would I would be the decision
trading based on that one variable and
create and save 5-leaf norms right so
you would have a range of income within
each one of those and then each each one
of the leaf nodes will have some event
rate right so you could actually replace
the income variable with a new variable
that actually takes on the event rate
within that so that way there is a
nonlinear relationship in income you can
actually capture that so then after you
transform the variable that way
and actually do a positive National
lasso or something which is been here
but actually you have the non-linearity
in built into them so you could you
could definitely extend some of the
ideas here
so then multicollinearity right so what
if two or more variables are highly
correlated with with each other so there
you can use something called condition
index which is just another way to look
at the eigen values right so the idea is
to again look at the correlation matrix
and you could do having value
decomposition for eigen vectors in this
way so if the condition index is greater
than 30 then you want to look at that on
there laughter so whichever variable has
highest loading then I will actually can
be dropped because it is actually kind
of contributing to multicollinearity so
in this case basically x1 x2 and x3 are
correlated with each other but what I
would do is I would drop the one
variable that has the highest loading
and then I'm rewrite because after
dropping one variable you may actually
eliminate that multicollinearity problem
right that is existing between those
three variables so so the way I do it so
this is the code and again we don't have
a lot of time to go through this but I'm
using NP numpy for eigenvalue
decomposition and this is my condition
index right if it's already less than 30
then I break I also want to control for
minimum variables to keep right so if I
I don't want to keep going until like I
end up with like three variables or
something right so I am trying to
control for that in this loop as well
and then the idea is same basically
delete that row and column in the
correlation matrix and reiterate right
so before you have before you actually
take care of multicollinearity your
collagen matrix might look like this
well a lot of the variables have very
high correlations
right plus one or negative one
but after doing multicolinearity now you
will still have someone to come in and
in the data because it's it's not it's
not possible using this technique to
eliminate completely so there are some
variables that are still correlated but
it's only about five six point sixty
five or something right so you have
reduce multipolarity in the data now
just four actually forgot mentioned
multicollinearity is not necessarily a
issue all you all you can about this
prediction but it can be an issue if you
care about the explanation but if you
have multi good in heavy in your data
then your coefficients are gonna be
walking right and it's gonna be
difficult to explain really due
importance of your predictors in the
model so if you do want to eliminate
multicollinearity
then you can use PCA principal component
analysis right so this is a
dimensionality reduction technique most
of you guys problem part of it and
familiar with it that emphasizes
variation so if you have thousand
variables one thousand variables then by
doing the principal component analysis
you can and you can have one thousand
things about components and then even
you get there like in values and some
other stuff that we'll look at on the
next slide we decide how many
complements you wanna keep and by
keeping fewer number of columns you may
be able to explain most of variation
that exists in your data right now I
don't recommend using this for
supervised learning problems actually
because this method actually only cares
about the variation so you may have your
number one component that has that
explains 25% of the variation in the
data but variation in that direction may
not be very useful for whatever you are
trying to predict right so you have
principal so basically the idea is this
right so if you have thousands if you
were to do supervised learning problem
using then you start with thousand
variables you would do your PCA you
retain
let's say 50 components and you take
those 50 components to build your
supervised learning problem do to build
a model right but I haven't seen this
work very well and supervised in
unsupervised learning problems its and
useful if you are doing clustering or
something and you have thousands of
variables and it's often difficult to
find clusters in that high dimensional
space so it may make sense to reduce
your dimensionality do pca
just focus on top fifty or something and
then do clustering it's it's usually
relatively easier to find clusters in a
smaller dimensional space so in order to
decide how many billions of other
components you want to keep you would
look at something called a scree plot
and try to find an elbow in the curve
right so in this case you may say you
may say that hey I want to keep me
somewhere around 1450 principal
components this one actually only shows
the top top 300 right there are more
actually but so you can make it's a kind
of subjective judgment how many
components you want to keep these are
the four things you want to look at
right I'll go in the car what percentage
of variance is explained by if you keep
50 then you are gonna be able to retain
65% of the variation in the data so you
would lose that to 25% variation right
so there's some loss there earlier this
year actually an odbc Austin open data
science conference I just talked about
three different ways to automatically
programmatically some curve right it's
visually you might think of so there are
a couple of techniques three techniques
that I talked about if anyone is
interested I'll be happy to discuss
those later so in Python it's really
easy again to do principal component
analysis I do recommend doing the
standardizing the data before you
actually do PCA because of the two
control for the different scale of
variables right this code just plots the
data that we saw on the on the previous
slide so then there's cluster analysis
now again this is another technique that
most of your time David
it's a dimensional reduction technique
which emphasizes correlation or
similarity so it's in a way conceptually
it's similar to PCA right but what it
does now traditionally cluster analysis
is used to group find groups of records
or lobes I check here if you have
customer little dataset then you do
Kimi's or something to find groups of
customers that are similar to each other
and similar to each other as possible
and as different from other people as
possible but you can use the same
concept for variable clustering as well
to find clusters of columns in your data
right
so that is similar to PCA you will do a
variable first friend prospers then from
each cluster you want to somehow you
either either wanted a presentation of
each cluster centroid for instance or
make it average or something or you can
pick the best variable from each cluster
the variable that represents that trust
or best and take those so if in
scikit-learn by the way if you any of
the code if you don't see import
statement usually most of the stuff is a
scikit-learn right number is NP and as
is PD right so in this case feature
agglomeration that's the function that I
that that can be used to do this so in
this case I just say 10 plus will give
me ten clusters but you can pay it on
with that number and see which one works
best to give you the best result and
then you transform the data so in this
case train bar plus will have ten
columns that you can use from online he
penned in in Python the ten variable the
ten columns that you have actually send
forms of those clusters which which
might not be very useful right it's
definitely not meaningful because those
ten variables can be X but you can't
explain those variables right
but in says any sense users by the way I
used to do sense a lot I still use cells
to some extent
so in tests there's a profitless that
actually lets you pick the best variable
the best representative the variable
that best represents that cluster and
you can take those variables then that
would be meaningful
you can explain those variables right so
so all the techniques that I talked
about so far wherever I say anything you
can drop those variables you always want
to check the correlation with the target
to make sure that you're not dropping
something that is useful but after you
have done all those are some of those
six steps or seven tests and stairs if
you have now the variables of those you
know 1900 that you started with so now
as a final thing what I usually do is I
can do one more iteration of look at
correlation with the target and see if
there's some kind and this is the wrong
term here draw a line you could say that
there's an elbow here but then you would
be keeping so see very few variables
right but if you see a long tail here
then you can eliminate those variables
we cannot marry correlated with the
target
so for the next three techniques are
kind of very similar in principle so I
combined them together
former selection backward selections and
stepwise so the power selection the
conceptually it's very technological
right the idea is to one way to do that
if you have 500 variables then you would
do 500 one variable model right and you
would see which way a bit more
eventually is the best in the end of the
curve are something else right then then
you would want to add another the second
can get computed computationally very
intensive because the number of
permutations are never so high so one
way to one that is you already solved
the variables by using some some some
writing unit so you can write and then
the idea is to kind of keep adding
variables this way and then track how
much improvement you get in your area
under the curve whatever metric you are
using to evaluate your model and once
you reach a plateau then you can say
that okay I want to stop at 10 or 16 or
something right
that's after that after I have 69 was in
my model adding the seventeenth variable
actually marginal weights it doesn't
really improve the performance of the
model so you can stop there and you can
have a 16 minute more backward
elimination it's called in scikit-learn
it's called recursive feature
elimination are Fe
there's a function for that that just
approaches the whole problem from the
other end of the spectrum if you know
final variables which and instead of it
then you would start with you would
throw all variables in your model and
then
and start eliminating variables that are
not not very useful in your model right
so inside learn you can actually
automatically do that using our Fe X
basically and then stepwise selection
actually combines the best of the -
right so you it approaches the problem
in a forward direction but then after
some point after you have that saved six
variables it's again it's going to
evaluate whether and whether it makes
sense to draw any of the variables that
we added earlier right so after adding
six variables if the second variable
that we added it's not doing much then
if you draw it I think your sense users
this all going to be very familiar yep
so this is how I do that in Python so I
have a pre-existing pre sorted list of
variables and I'm gonna keep adding I'm
gonna add one variable at a time and
then I track the the ROC right after you
after I edit variable actually and in
this case I'm actually actually testing
to make sure because this is the this is
velocity regression problem actually
this is love in this case I use positive
regression so I'm also checking to make
sure that none of the Sun is I've felt
I'm so if a variable has a positive
correlation with the target and if I add
that's it another variable and if that
flips the sign of the coefficient and I
want I don't add that variable because
it's actually messing up its it's
basically happening you don't
multicollinearity so we have 110 million
steps I'm gonna rush through the last
two lasso is a really cool technique
that was interesting that was very new I
think it was introduced sometime in the
mid 90s from Stanford it actually kills
two birds in one stone right so it it
allows you to find the coefficients for
your variables for the predictors in the
model and it also selects the best set
of my right so it doesn't have that
follow the previous methods that I
talked about it does have the first
mover bias right so if you start with
one variable you may end up with a
different set of twelve variables that
are best but if you start with maybe the
variable that is not the strong
the second best you may end up with a
better solution so it has possible
revised la so doesn't have that right so
so really it's really kind of logistic
regression kind of technique which uses
a absolute error rather than a squared
error right so you can just change the
penalty term and C is the penalty
penalty parameter that you can actually
you can find out which one is the best
for your data and then three based this
is where some of the non-linearity comes
into play right so you can use extra
three classifier in
scikit-learn to actually do in this case
100 different trees 100 different sub
samples and then excuse me if a variable
so so it's gonna be 100 trees right and
if one variable appears in all of the
hundred trees then ten variables gonna
have a higher ranking is it's more
important for a year so so you're gonna
get a ranked ordered list of variables
at the end of this right that you can
use for modeling so this is the workflow
usually change this and you can again
improvise and stuff like that but first
I do missing values then I do Catamount
evaluation then you can for
multicollinearity you can take three
different tracks right depending on
whatever you are trying to do then
finally i look at the correlation with
the target and then at the end I may
have only 100 or 200 variables that I
will use in the whole machine learning
algorithm this is the comparison real
quick easy I didn't really do very well
which is not surprising Wireless
actually surprisingly did very well
actually in the top ten or fifteen
percentile it actually outperform all of
the models but in general overall those
digression did the best
so it had a C statistic of 0.0 point
seventy two I actually did not
participate in this in this in this
competition so I don't know how I felt
according to other participants but this
is a pretty good model in my opinion
decision tree of surprised I'm sure
there is a way to improve but I just
time to tinker with different you know
different variables and stuff like that
but it is surprising that deep decision
tree didn't do very well and this is the
kitchen sink approach the red line right
which has 1900 and some variables so it
didn't have a see status signal up a
eighty under the column point sixty
three which is still better than coin
flip but you can see that it's it's not
doing very well so since it is almost
lunchtime I want to end this video with
picture of food so Nikita is really like
a block all you can eat buffet right you
have so many different items that you
can choose from you can go crazy any of
something from everything right but a
better approach is to watch what you eat
right if you have calories in it
if you have if you are watching a very
low calorie vegetarian unlike me then
you would try to avoid some items stay
away from some items and that's
basically the concept of featured
reduction as well it's it's about
focusing on the variables that are
valuable that are useful to have
meaningful for the problem that you are
trying to solve so that's that's all I
had thank you so sorry
so I'm gonna take all the questions
right now I think we have five of
17-under outside I'm available and
afterwards if you want to reach me
yeah so the question is in stepwise
selection process right why would you
let's say you you you you start with the
best better than one oh you had five
more and then you're adding the sticks
very bold and now you may see that the
second variable that we added it's not
it's not very meaningful anymore now
then the reason why that happen is
because of multicollinearity right
because the the steps that I discussed
the bad guys as well as the
multicollinearity helps us reduce is
multicollinearity but it doesn't
eliminate it so it just essentially
means that just expendable that we're
trying to add as a is multiple is
correlated with the second variable
chakra at the sixth one the second one
is not doing much so then it's a race
between sixth and second 3021 key so you
could actually know that the coefficient
of each of those variables and in fact
the one that is not the p-value is not
significant but it's kind of generalized
detachment but he'd use a different
penalty function so long digression use
a square error
yeah but I mean I guess are you saying
yes but it's it's so it's about the I
think many when you when you have a mean
going back to like a traditional linear
regression framework when you are trying
to where you're trying to draw a line in
your data right which how do you want to
draw the line right when you have a so
I'm going to be linear regression right
so the error that is calculated in
monastic digression into a square error
impossible is actually absolutely dead
the number of variables that I have in
different booth has a different set of
variables because porn object I use that
all stepwise selection process which
which may have a very different set of
variables that also it all right last
one is like that the only thing I did
not so it's trying to optimize the
penalty to see the C value the televi
variable right so so both are different
models like how can you say that right
right yep that's right I think there
were two other
what happens I mean they don't
necessarily have to be in Ireland never
mentioned right never even if you are
doing multiple linearity but actually
always checking the correlation
coefficients that have you as well
because you always want to be an even if
you have thousands of variables long as
one be careful you don't throw this
something without checking its
correlation with the target if it does
have higher correlation that you want to
keep them you won't expect it and you
want trying to find a way to use that
model you use that variable in the model
right but you could argue that I had
first thing I want to do this I just
want to check the coordination with the
target and if there's a long tail you
would drop those variables and then you
could do what do you need another stuff
right you could definitely do that
it they don't have to s very formal in
order outside okay so I think there was
one of the question of I'll take it
outside you yeah thank you